it was interesting watching the clip of
the conversation which is now 40-plus
years old and it was after I'd spent a
and all night an all-nighter on that
that I began to notice this phenomenon
of the the alignment really in the in
the way that Yuri was talking of the cut
point with the tendency of the actor in
this case Gene Hackman to blink very
close to that cut point and I didn't
know what to make of it and I went out
to get some breakfast and I happened to
pass by a Christian Science reading room
this is like Sunday morning at you know
six o'clock in the morning so it was
very lonely area of the city but there
was an interview with John Huston who
had just made Fat City and he was
talking to the inner to the journalist
about focus of attention and how between
looking at John Huston and looking at
the lamp in the room
the interviewer his eyes would would
blink and his point was that's what the
cut is that the intervening material is
not important the lamp is important
because I asked you to look at it and
now I'm important because you're looking
at me said John Huston but in between is
just noise and so there is a lowering of
the threshold a blink to kind of clear
the ground away and bring in two more
close mental juxtaposition the lamp and
John Huston and that was when the light
went on and I thought oh that's what's
going on and then I began watching
people and engaging them in conversation
and just being very observant of when do
they blink and this pattern began to
emerge which it would be very
interesting to do a mass survey using
infrared light of an audience and see
if the blink points of a large number of
people coincide the metaphor would be
somebody who's designing a boat you know
you're you're building the boat in a
warehouse type environment but the sea
is not very far from your thoughts
because this boat has to survive in the
ocean and similarly a film is a kind of
yacht that has to survive in the sea of
audience participation and so you know
we're designing the boat to be beautiful
just on its own as a piece of sculpture
and so the film also should be beautiful
on its own but we know that it has to
survive the kind of intensity mental
intensity that an audience will subject
the film to and so yeah we we think
about it perhaps not a hundred percent
of the time but just the way a naval
architect thinks of the sea filmmakers
think of the audience as I was doing a
smaller budget at film you there are
tens of millions of dollars is spent on
CGI to get the same type of brain
activity that you can get I learned
early on with swingers when I made that
phone call it was leaving messages and
the whole audience would squirm then I
was leaving all these messages on the
answering machine it was awful and you
could really if you have good
storytelling you can get the same
response it's also a chef there was a
lot of food sequences and I noticed that
people would groan as they showed
brisket being uncovered in an in a
smoker in Austin Texas and so there are
analog tools to get those those things
but but when you learn what it is you
really essentially as walter saying you
want that boat to be on the water you
want to work that room you want people
to connect with what you're doing
Birdman which is a is coming out
they've it's it's sensibly no cuts you
know and but there's but there are cuts
but you stitch and if you look at
children of men there's a sequence where
or there's a true detective on
television
so people are really pushing the
boundaries because it because an
intrinsic tension takes place when there
aren't any cuts either you don't realize
in gravity the tension begins to be
generated when you realize there's a
whole reel without any cuts then you
might not notice it consciously but you
feel yourself becoming uncomfortable and
so the cutting pattern creates a it also
changes what the relationship of what
you can do with sound in a theatrical
setting if you have a film with a lot of
quick cuts and dialogue at the same time
the beginning of social network for
instance there's almost a pull towards
the center that it's very difficult to
do surround type sounds in that
environment whereas gravity the first 17
minutes there's no cut and they were
able to use the whole theater and move
the dialogue around the theater and it
was not disorienting whereas norm in a
normal even in a normal big-budget
spectacular film too much of that
becomes very distracting because of the
violence of the cut and you know we have
to think for a second about how violent
the cut is that it's the total
displacement of your field of vision in
an instant and yet the mind is happy you
know ken can take it and not only can
take it but but in a sense loves it the
cutting is not just something that we
have to do because of the discontinuous
nature of the way we shoot films we
actually both as filmmakers and
audiences like these sudden
juxtapositions of concepts kind of like
I was saying you know John Huston's face
to the lamp at this very basic level you
also don't forget this is one of the
curious things about the move from film
to digital when you see a film in a
theatre if that film is two hours long
you're spending one hour in darkness
because for every frame there is an
equal amount of time where there's
nothing on the screen and your mind is
primarily engaged in removing the
darkness
but if you take a spot meter to a film
and a film film and point the spot meter
at the screen you see the needle going
crazy because every frame is causing a
burst of light and then dark light dark
light dark and your mind is busy at that
very primal level smoothing all that out
that does not happen with digital
projection digital projection is an
image and then that image is instantly
replaced by another image and before
digital really took off I wondered are
we gonna you know throw the baby out
with the bathwater at some level this
alternation of light and dark engages us
at this primary sensory level and when
that's going on is some gas gonna go out
of the balloon but it clearly is not as
not happening